foreign
marketing it's an evolving industry
changing how businesses connect with
their customers it's an art of promoting
products or Services through digital
channels like search engines social
media email and websites with over 4.9
billion internet users worldwide digital
marketing has become essential for
businesses of all size to reach Their
audience and drive growth in fact
studies show that digital marketing
efforts have an Roa of 122 percent which
is four times higher than traditional
marketing from SEO and PPC to content
marketing and social media digital
marketing offers various strategies to
help businesses connect with their
customers and boost their bottom line so
buckle up and get ready to dive into the
exciting world of digital marketing but
before we get into the Integrity of
things let me tell you about simpilance
post-agent programming digital marketing
created in collaboration with Purdue
University and meta blueprint with
master classes delivered by Purdue
faculty industry projects from five
domains and 14 plus course and projects
this course offers hands-on experience
and real world case study least from
companies like Yahoo Acker and
TripAdvisor you'll also receive a meta
certified digital marketing associate
exam voucher worth 99 and become
eligible to be part of the Purdue
University Alumni Association plus with
course alignment to Facebook Google ads
and analytics HootSuite and SC ranking
certification you will have everything
you need to become a confident and
successful digital marketer so what are
you waiting for sign up now and fast
track your career in digital marketing
you can find the course Link in the
description box below so without any
further Ado let's get started Espionage
a competitive intelligence tool that
monitors the entire conversion funnel
and provides data on competitors they
were having trouble with their marketing
blog as it was not directing enough
referral traffic to the main website now
to solve this the digital marketing team
used an Optimum exit intent pop-up to
their blog asking visitors if they would
like to download their competitors most
profitable PPC and SEO keywords the
pop-up only appeared on exit intent
after a visitor spent at least 10
seconds on the blog the popover was
displayed 4 1144 times in one month
achieving a 5.47 conversion rate proving
the efficiency and accuracy of the
pop-up this just proves how much
importance a digital marketer holds for
any business and with the increasing
importance of digital marketing in
businesses the demand for digital
marketing professionals is also growing
the scope of digital marketing offers a
promising career with opportunities for
growth and specialization now let's dive
into some of the most popular job roles
in digital marketing and see what each
job role entails first the digital
marketing manager digital marketing
manager responsible for overseeing all
digital marketing activities creating
strategies and managing a team with
excellent leadership skills the salary
for a digital marketing manager in U.S
is approximately 71 000 per year while
in India it's around 7 lakhs per year
depending on the size of the company and
level of experience next search engine
optimization specialist an SEO
specialist is responsible for optimizing
website content and structure to improve
its visibility and ranking on the search
engine this roles requires a lot of
knowledge on SEO tools keyword research
and Technical SEO optimization the
salary of an SEO specialist in Us is
around fifty four thousand dollars while
in India it's around three lakh per year
depending on the experience level and
location as well next we have
pay-per-click specialist a PPC
specialist manages online advertising
campaigns on platforms like Google ads
and Facebook ads this rules requires PPC
campaigns keyword research and bid
management knowledge the salary for a
PPC specialist in Us is around fifty
thousand dollars per year while in India
it's around 6 lakh per year depending on
the experience level and location next
we have the social media marketing
specialist a social media marketing
specialist is responsible for creating
and executing social media marketing
campaigns on various social media
platforms like Facebook Twitter
Instagram LinkedIn and others this role
requires creativity excellent
communication skills knowledge of social
media analytics now the salary for a
social media marketing specialist in Us
is around forty eight thousand dollars
per year while in India it's around 4
lakh per year depending on experience
level and location as well and at last
the email marketing specialist an email
marketing specialist is responsible for
creating and managing email marketing
campaigns to reach out to potential and
existing customer list increase customer
loyalty and drive sales salary for an
email marketing specialist is sixty
thousand dollars per year in India it's
around 3.5 lakhs per year depending upon
the level of experience and location
let's talk about how skills impact
service and digital marketing a career
in digital marketing requires a range of
skills and abilities the salary
difference between a person who is new
to the industry and a person with some
skills in digital marketing can vary
depending on various factors such as
location job role experience and
Industry entry level digital marketing
positions offered around thirty thousand
dollars to forty thousand dollars per
year for someone with no skills and
around forty thousand to fifty thousand
dollars for someone with having some
skills now as someone with some skills
gain experience and expertise but their
salaries can increase significantly but
now you may ask how you can obtain these
skills then let's talk about some
certifications certifications in digital
marketing can significantly impact
salaries with professionals earning up
to 20 more than their non-certified
counterparts certifications demonstrate
knowledge and expertise in a specific
area of digital marketing making
candidates more attractive to potential
employers entry level certifications
like Google analytics or Google ads can
help boost salaries for these starting
in this field while more advanced
certifications like HubSpot or whose
suit can increase wages for those with
more experience employers value
certifications and see them as an
indicator of skills and knowledge and
better job opportunities let me tell you
about simply Love's digital marketing
specialist Masters program co-created
with Facebook to transform you into a
digital marketing specialist in domains
like SEO social media pay-per-click
conversion optimization digital
analytics content mobile and email
marketing the certification is aligned
with top digital marketing
certifications from Facebook blueprint
omcp Google ads and analytics HootSuite
HubSpot offering 45 plus projects and
case studies to learn more about this
course click the link in the description
box below but before we continue let's
find out what our Learners have to say
about our courses change is inevitable
but growth is optional
for me both came hand in hand
I successfully changed my career from
software development to digital
marketing and simply learn present at
the perfect route hi I'm rimajraf from
Dubai and I have completed the pgp in
digital marketing from Simply learn with
Purdue University when I shifted to
Dubai from Sri Lanka in 2015 I joined a
group of company as a software engineer
but my interest in content creation
attracted me towards the marketing
industry intrigued by the marketing
functions I decided to take up a
challenge that would change my life
forever I aim for a career change as
risky as it was the rewards were truly
overwhelming even though the journey
wasn't easy the pgp in digital marketing
with Purdue University acted as not only
a catalyst but a game changer for my
career change with no profiting
certification in marketing domain it was
difficult for me to transition and
change my career towards completely
so I decided to upskill with the
professional certification program
I just simply learn because of its
tremendously High waiting to be rated as
one of the best Education portal online
worldwide is surely promising not only
were the ratings high but also the
courses were economically charged the
modules were very informative and
amazing I still refer to those while in
the final stage of my course I told my
Superior about the certification program
I was doing and then it offered me a
digital marketing role in the marketing
department as a digital marketing
executive he that's how smooth it was
after working for a few years in the
same company as a digital marketing
executive I switched to a new role as a
digital marketing manager with this my
skill upgraded my salary increase and my
self-confident Boost alongside numerous
other positive outcomes I had a chance
to take a challenge and change my career
domain all together
and I took it So currently I'm pursuing
masters of Masters program from Simply
learn where I would complete a Masters
program including artificial intelligent
cloud computing and devops and many more
growing requires moving out of our
comfort zones
keep learning keep growing now let's
check out some tips to help you learn
high-paying jobs digital marketing is a
growing industry and with it comes the
opportunity for lucrative careers here
are six tips to help you land a high
career job in digital marketing tip
number one gain expertise in digital
marketing a strong understanding of all
aspects of digital marketing is
essential to land a high-paying job keep
up with the latest trends and
continuously expand your Knowledge and
Skills tip number two build a strong
online presence create an online
portfolio showcasing your work and
achievements in digital marketing build
a social media presence and engage with
industry professionals to demonstrate
your expertise tip number three network
with Professionals in the industry
attend industry events join online
groups and forums and connect with other
Professionals in this field it can help
you learn about job opportunities and
get reference from people who already
work in that industry coming to tip
number four develop a specialty
specializing in a particular area of
digital marketing can make you a
valuable asset to an employer and help
you command a higher salary tip number
five showcase your results employees are
interested in hiring candidates with the
track record of producing results be
prepared to share your examples of your
success in digital marketing including
metrics that demonstrate the
effectiveness of campaigns you can be a
top candidate for high paying digital
marketing jobs by following all these
tips and that's it for this digital
marketing salary video If you like this
video then that like button and share it
with your peers and if you have any
questions you can drop them in the
comment section below to get more such
videos subscribe to our Channel until
next time stay safe and keep learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here